all right the great one mark levine
coming up in a few moments but first we
made you a promise
and that is we will not stop our quest
in terms of finding equal justice in
this country
new developments tonight new documents
released by the doj
show that multiple members of mueller's
team including the pitbull of robert
mueller
that would be andrew weissman actually
wipe
their department phones clean
like hillary before turning them over to
the inspector general get this many of
them
they all use the exact same suspicious
excuse
entering the wrong passwords too many
times
had to clean it then for example
weissman used the password
excuse for one device then claim oh i
accidentally you mean
like with a cloth you know i've wiped
another one clean
according to the documents well over a
dozen devices were wiped clean
so you ask yourself what was the mueller
team hiding
what are the odds that they would all
forget their passcodes and all make the
same stupid mistake
do you believe them i don't and of
course rather than focus on those
possible criminal violations you got the
compromise corrupt congenital liar
adam schiff rolling out yet another
russia hoax
months before the election he's lost it
because he's now trouty trotting out
another whistleblower is claiming
the suppression of key intelligence
about russian interference
we know they had none we know the
sub-source of steele said there's none
we know that comey was warned before he
signed the first of
three warrants there's no there there
don't trust the dossier hillary paid for
it and steele has an agenda like all the
other
shift shows this uh one is light on
facts heavy on hysteria and rage against
trump the attorney general saying there
could be more charges though
in the dorm investigation when please
and frankly it's time for accountability
it's now the facts make that clear the
evidence is overwhelming and
controversial
incontrovertible here's the president
earlier today
durham who is a very very respected man
and we're going to see what it is i
can't tell you that i can tell you this
i can tell you this they
they lied they cheated
they leaked they got caught they spied
on my campaign
never in history has there been anything
like this and i guarantee if the roles
were reversed and
i was on the democrat side people would
have been in jail
at the very highest level here with
reaction to all this senator lindsey
graham
senator i'm going to be blunt i don't
believe a word
this is not an accident i do not believe
that right the same people that were out
charging people for what they themselves
may have done here well if you can't
manage your own phone why should we
trust you to investigate a crime so
i guess they just ran out of hammers and
bleach bleaching material
so the question is did they obstruct
justice
did they intentionally uh delete
information from their phone
because horowitz was on on the case
that's the question for durham my job as
chairman of the judiciary committee
is to find out how the department of
justice and the fbi
uh got crossfire hurricanes so wrong why
they
lied to the fisa court to make sure it
never happens again
as to future prosecutions i would be
shocked if the only person prosecuted is
klein smith
so they went after you well let's stay
there
you believe it will be more how was
james comey escape here
he's so average well here's three
warrants he was worn before the first
one
the sub source told him that none of
this
is real they admit now there was no
evidence a collusion the media mob
lied mueller's team lied they never
should have had mueller even appointed
senator
they dragged the country through hell
right
so i i made an invitation to comey
mccabe
and strzok to come before the committee
they will be
respectfully treated to answer questions
about the horowitz report
none of them have testified since
horowitz issued his report
i am working with their lawyers to try
to get them into the committee
so we can ask questions and let them
give answers
to the questions we've been asking on
this show they may have good
answers but they need to be asked the
question okay
so where are we with this and what about
these new developments
because i think they owe us answers that
they all
know made password errors so now we're
just going to erase the phone
completely wipe it clean you mean like
with a cloth
that kind of clean bleach bit clean
hammer clean
we cannot live in a country where this
is tolerated
trump russia look how much money they
spent how many agents were involved
investigating
all things trump and russia how many
subpoenas issued
how many lives turned upside down the
question for
me uh was there a double standard here
it's pretty obvious to me there was
but stay tuned sean uh you think you're
mad about the phone's been wiped
stay tuned uh we'll talk in about 10 or
12 days and we'll see if there's
something else
you could get mad about just stay tuned
i hate when you're basically telling me
you know something i don't know
uh i hate that by the way uh congrats on
your campaign you're doing well against
barbara streisand and rosie and uh
by the way uh people can get all this
information on your website
yeah lindsey lindseygram.com my
opponent's gonna raise 75 million
dollars from every liberal in the
country trying to defeat me
five or ten bucks goes a long way we
need to keep this seat
well i was talking more about the
information about the mueller
investigation but that's okay it's all
good thank you
well that that's coming you're right you
we need south carolina not to be able to
lose
if the republicans lose the senate i
gotta never hear about this crap again
that's true we need the truth